if our cyberpunk lore series has got you
impatiently awaiting the arrival of
cyberpunk 2077 then you
are not alone to help you pass the time
we've compiled a list of great
cyberpunky books
movies and games for you to tuck into
you'll probably have guessed this one
would make the list but i highly
recommend checking out cyberpunk 2020
the dystopian tabletop game that forms
the basis for cyberpunk 2077.
originally written by mike pondsmith in
1988 the tabletop rpg covers an
alternative timeline of world events
occurring between 2013 and 2045.
as to the nature of those world events
well check out our extensive lore videos
but the game consists of 10 key roles to
choose from in character creation
difficulty values to contest with net
running and combat centered around
lethality there's no better place to
start than the game's fourth edition
cyberpunk red if you're a tabletop fan
waiting for 2077 to come out
ponsmith told dicebreaker that
bladerunner and walter john williams
double hardwired were inspirations for
cyberpunk though a number of people
assumed that william gibson's
neuromancer also helped spawn the
popular rpg
pondsmith didn't actually read
neuromancer until sometime later but
that doesn't mean
you shouldn't check it out neuromancer
burning chrome and mona lisa overdrive
are known together as the spawn trilogy
gibson's novels were published around
the mid-80s and look at a fictional
future where the world is ruled by
corporations
the novel also explores the unintended
consequences of rampant technology
including mind machine links the
evolution of ai and a global information
space
that gibson called cyberspace the term
had been used once before but not
in reference to a digital space gibson's
works are considered to be seminal
entries in the cyberpunk genre
that is alongside philip k dick's 1968
novel do androids dream of electric
sheep
which served as the narrative basis for
both blade runner films and is
responsible in large part for kicking
off the new wave science fiction
movement
and subsequently the cyberpunk sub-genre
his 1977 sci-fi novel a scanner darkly
was also
set in a dystopian future california and
was the basis for richard linklater's
2006 film of the same name starring
keanu reeves
two hemispheres of my brain are
competing
yes so there's another 2077 connection
for you there
if you're just not a book person no
worries there's plenty of cyberpunky
goodness to be found in more visual
mediums
look it goes without saying that you
should definitely watch the phenomenal
blade runner movies
but if you haven't already you should
also check out mad max fury road
apart from being in my opinion and
almost perfectly crafted film
it effectively captures the cyberpunk
subgenre staple of as bruce sterling
writes in the preface to gibson's book
burning chrome
a combination of low life and high tech
where technological advancements are
starkly contrasted against radical
social unrest
the locations and vibe of the original
mad max movies also serve as a great
primer for cyberpunk 2077's
badlands outside of night city and the
nomad path that kicks off there
fury road is also worth your time
because charlie's theron is super cool
almost everyone is aussie and a dude
plays a flame-throwing guitar on the
front of a speeding amp riddled truck
good movie as for what else you can
watch on the big screen check out ghost
in the shell
no not that ghost in the shell there we
go based on the manga of the same name
this 1995 anime cyberpunk film follows
cyborg public security agent
motoko kusanagi on her mission to hunt
down a hacker called the puppet master
in 2029 the narrative touches on themes
of philosophy
human identity and the implications of
technological advancements in really
fascinating ways
it's well worth a watch if you haven't
seen it or if you only caught the scarjo
one
but hey maybe your ideal prep before
playing cyberpunk 2077
is just to play other great cyberpunk
video games in which case your first
stop should be blooper teams observer
the critically acclaimed psychological
horror game follows detective daniel
lazarsky portrayed by none other than
rutger hauer well i'm not a vegetable
yet
lazarsky can hack other people's minds
in order to interrogate them and utilize
augmented vision to scan electronic
devices and biological evidence
the game is set in 2084 in krakow after
a devastating digital plague
gamespot reviewer david rayfield praised
the game's superbly detailed
environments
evocative sound design and the cyberpunk
story which he called one of the most
intriguing to be found in the genre in
years
when it comes to other tech heavy gaming
franchises there's probably one that
comes to mind first
deus ex deus ex first entry was
developed by ion storm in 2000.
the series continued over the 2000s with
invisible war
human revolution the fall and mankind
divided the games take place within a
future earth which is devolved into a
dystopian cyberpunk society
yeah another one multiple organizations
vie for control while the world is at
war with a nanovirus called the grey
death
in the middle of it all is our
protagonist nano augmented newbie agent
jc denton aside from its cyberpunk
narrative themes the gameplay is
designed to be flexible
across multiple gameplay styles it
incorporates styles across the action
role-playing
stealth and first-person shooter genres
much like cyberpunk 2077 there's an
emphasis on player choice
npc relationships and player agency
granted through the game's rpg elements
if turn-based rpgs are your thing it's
worth checking out the dense and
intriguing
shadow run series based on the tabletop
game of the same name
the game takes place in a cyberpunk
fantasy world in 2054 and you play as a
shadow runner much like cyberpunk's
shadowrunners are mercs for hire
surviving on skill and instinct and must
navigate a world
ruled by mega corporations shadowrun
gained traction from its pen and paper
roots by blending the vastly popular rpg
with the most popular sci-fi media other
honorable mentions in the video game
realm
include watch dogs if what you're really
after is that hacking fix
flying wild hog cyberpunk fps hard reset
for shooter fans
and cyberpunk narrative adventure the
red strings club which should state
those who like to talk the talk
in a deep neon cyberpunk world with
plenty going on beneath the surface
let me know down in that comment box
what your favorite cyberpunk
books movies and games are and between
this and our cyberpunk lore series we'll
have you all ready to go for 2077 by the
time it releases
we'll see you again soon